i'm matt schwartz i was an mba in
stanford's 2017 class and i'm the
co-founder and ceo of afresh and i'm
nathan fenner mba class of 2017 and i'm
the co-founder and president of afresh
around the world hundreds of billions of
dollars of fresh food are thrown away
every year
and that fresh food represents
millions and millions of tons of
greenhouse gases that are created both
in the landfills after they're thrown
away and also in the energy that's used
to grow distribute produce that that
food
it's a really corny story that nathan
hates when i share when i first met him
it was at an admit weekend to the gsb
after spending a few days with nathan i
called my mom and i told her i'm going
to start a company with this guy i think
i chose
building this company for the
opportunity to work with matt i think
matt was frequently dismissed at
business school because he's so earnest
but i was just thoroughly impressed with
him and saw someone who i was really
kind of my counterpoint in terms of my
values and how i saw the world in the
summer between our years at the mba
program nathan and i signed up for an
independent research study with a gsb
lecturer in which we did this big
investigation of the fresh food supply
chain talking to a bunch of businesses
there was just an absolute technology
gap across the board
and that in turn culminated in us
identifying the immediate opportunity
for afresh a mentor once told me look
for areas that are really
underpenetrated by technology find that
field where that initial technological
innovation really really moves the
needle and so what we do as a company is
we've built the first of its kind
fresh food
first supply chain technology for the
fresh food industry food more so than
any other industry shapes the health of
people
and our planet it'd be better around the
world if people ate more fresh food
at the same time fresh food is really
costly one of the biggest drivers of
that cost is the fact that so much of it
is wasted
with what we're doing at afresh we've
prevented on order of 10 million pounds
of cumulative food waste reduction at
this point
i think the ability to go to work every
day knowing that every ounce of sweat
that we put in
has that positive impact is the thing
that motivates us and the team
you